escudier dit non non grâce à vous après
j'ai pu faire deux années merveilleuses
sur gulli et gérald brice viret
ouais c'est vous ne m'aviez hier un
petit peu aidé à ce moment là aussi
voilà donc je vous ai pas laissé tomber
non non non voilà et ouais c'est très
bien de qui tu es avec moi la radio
travaille encore avec moi oui oui un
bouquin qui est génial je sais pas où
tout est maintenant qu on ne sort pas
bien c'est génial oui quid de la rentrée
parce que on est bientôt à la fin de la
saison l'a donc oui c'est rapport à la
rentrée webb à la rentrée prochaine
bush
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais un jour ou l'autre à toutes
vos questions et cherrier voilà merci
chéri toi bachir est ce que tu veux
savoir quelque chose sur la rentrée sur
quoi se disent pas tout ça alors les
récents parlent vraiment de la halle à
l'aune de ce qui se passe ici un franco
français donc qu'est ce qui a inquiété
mais qu'est ce que tu as quelque chose à
bien mon bébé bien aéré d'après meité
avait coutume à la casse
j'aimerais bien être animateur sur ses
stars à nyon vd sur ses stars mais la
musique band tout de suite je suis un
pur culture c'est ça ouais géré à ce que
je peux faire de l'argent non c'est bon
ça va la considère que c'est
allez mes questions sous la nuit on
hésite ou pas mais prochainement des
questions mais sachez le l'année
prochaine
quoi qu'il arrive quoi qu'il advienne
des pmp sera à l'antenne
ouais alors avec lui et sur quelle
chaîne et avec qui avec ses considéré
dès maintenant que la porte est ouverte
[Applaudissements]
encore bien dormir avec avec la mp
l'année prochaine quoi vous présenter je
présenterai tué par balles à moi non
parce que transhumance
on n'a aucune proposition ailleurs dans
mais je le comprends
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que les questions non non non
vous ça vous serez de la partie l'année
prochaine ah c'est pas laquelle vous
serez d'apt et où seraient de la partie
de la gamme et bas que vous avez des
questions d'autres questions allez-y je
vous fais regarder il est 19h10 je fais
des questions jusqu'à 19 12 vous avez
dit est ce que vous êtes en train de
réfléchir actuellement à d'autres
émissions sur la grille et de ses 8 ou
du groupe
oui oui d'accord avec ça concerne vous
ça concerne des gens en tout cas une
chose est sûre ça ne vous concerne donc
la question n'a encore car en dieu mais
alors il ya des rumeurs qui disent que
vous allez retourner à la radio vrai ou
pas vrai ou faux je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas qui je vous le jure
et c'est vrai alors qu'il est
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas à 19 ans je
ne sais pas bon allez jamais une
matinale jamais une matinale a donc ça
c'est sûr et certain
jusqu'à quel point votre emploi du temps
et définies pour l'année prochaine entre
les divers projets ont raté perron de
par la valeur c'est sûr et certain
ok tu dis qu'il y aura une amodiations
vous aurez envie de faire autre chose en
plus de la numéro une nouvelle émission
à y aura une nouvelle émission très très
grosse émission vous arrivez par vos
recettes
très vite vous allez je pense à dori un
trait ça va et événementiel et prime des
dépôts où les oui est ce que vous allez
diriger prochainement une télévision ou
une radio ouï l'afl animaux évoluent
garder non c'est pas du tout à l'ordre
du jour voyez dernière vous avez envie
d'aller sur une autre chaîne pas du tout
plu groupe alors mais il avait nié la
vente plein dans la grotte du coup je
suis dans le groupe je veux dire quand
on est dans un groupe mais les beatles
il sont paniqués les religions non
voulait dire mais sans rien et les magic
system
c'est bon pas dans leur voyage ils vont
pas les imaginer pourquoi j'ai une
petite ligne dure at il des
augmentations aller